[موسيقى]
مساء الخير من الامور العجيبه الغريبه انه
بعد مرور 20 سنه على الغزو الامريكي
المشؤوم للعراق ما زال السؤال الاكثر
الحاحا حتى الان هو لماذا غزت امريكا اصلا
العراق السؤال ده مش مطروح في العراق ولا
في العالم العربي فقدمت روح في الولايات
المتحده نفسها
والسؤال ده مطروح ببساطه لان كل الاسباب
التي ساقتها اداره جورج بوش ليه شن الحرب
على العراق بدت متهافته قبل الغزو وثبت
انها خاطئه بعد اندلاع الحرب اذكر حضراتكم
بشكل سريع انه الاداره الامريكيه ساقت كل
سبب ممكن حتى تتمكن من تبرير غزوها للعراق
بدا الحديث بانه صدام على علاقه بالضلعين
في الهجوم على الولايات المتحده فيها جمال
11 سبتمبر 2001 ثم انتقلوا الى امتلاكه
اسلحه الدمار شامل ومنها اسلحه كيميائيه
وبيولوجيه ثم ضخموا من هذا السيناريو بشكل
مخيف للامريكان وقالوا ان صدام ربما يعطي
هذه الاسلحه اسلحه الضمائر الشامل ليهاجم
بها الامريكان كما فعل فيه
كما حدث في سبتمبر 2001 ثم انتقلوا الى
اسباب اخرى لم تكن مطروحه في الحديث عن
العراق ولا غير العراق
هو كمبررات للحرب وهو ان صدام زعيم باطش
ديكتاتور يقمع شعبه وهذا مبرر للحرب يجب
ان نساعد العراقيين على ان يتمتعوا
بالحريه والديمقراطيه ثم بداوا يتحدثون عن
طموح اكبر املين في ان هذا هذه
الديمقراطيه وهذه الحريه تنتقل من العراق
الى كل منطقه الشرق الاوسط وبالتالي تنتهي
كل مشاكل الولايات المتحده في هذه المنطقه
المضطربه من العالم
الان الثابت بعد 20 سنه انه والواضح جدا
ان الاداره الامريكيه اتخذت قرارها بغزو
العراق ثم بدات تبحث عن ذرائع
لكن يبقى السؤال لماذا اختلقت اداره بوشك
كل هذه الذرائع لغزو العراق لماذا كل هذا
الحماس الجنوني للاطاحه بصدام حسين
وتدمير العراق وغزوها هذا بياخذنا الى
مجموعه من التفسيرات
وليس الاسباب يعني حتى الان لا احد يمتلك
سببا قاطعا عندنا تفسيرات بس ليه ما
عندناش اسباب لانه ببساطه رغم كل
التحقيقات اللي اجرتها المؤسسات الامريكيه
وغير الامريكيه ظلت اداره بوش متمسكه حتى
هذه اللحظه من مات منه ومن ما زال على قيد
الحياه ومن على قيد الحياه كثيرون متمسكين
بنفس الاسباب التي شنوا من اجلها الحرب
وقالوا فعلا كنا نعتقد ان لدي اسلحه دمار
شامل نعم اساءنا قراءه المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه بل وحملوا صدام حسين جزء من
المسؤوليه وقالوا اول مره نرى فيها رئيس
دوله
يتظاهر او يثير الشقوق عن احتمال امتلاكه
سلاحا يعني اسلحه دمار شامل يبدو ان
حساباته وفقا لهؤلاء انه اذا كان
الامريكان
شاكين في انه بيمتلك اسلحه دمار شامل فان
هذا سوف يرضعهم ولن يشجعهم على الهجوم
عليه
لكن بقطع النظر عن كل ذلك الحلقه دي مش عن
الاسباب ولا ملابسات الحرب اللي قتلت بحثا
احنا بنحاول نقيب على سؤال واحد لماذا
اختلقت اداره بوش كل هذه الذرائع لشن
الحرب على العراق الاجابه في تقديري
هو انه في البدايه الولايات المتحده اداره
بوش كانت بتبحث عن اي كبش فداء الكلام ده
كبش فداء ليه طبعا الولايات المتحده بكل
حولها وقوتها ضربت وهينت في 11 سبتمبر
2001 وكان هناك رغبه عارمه لدى الراي
العام الامريكي والاداره الامريكيه
بمعاقبه دوله ما طرف ما الكلام ده اللي
قاله جورج بوش الابن مش انا
اللي كان مسؤول عن مكافحه الارهاب في
المجلس القومي الامريكي قال نصا كده ان
بوش وهو يدخل
الى مركز عمليات الطوارئ في ليله 11
سبتمبر قال نصا
اس ترجمه ايه معناها يجب ان نبحث عن شخص
او عن دوله او عن طرف مشبعه ضربا
وهو من هو في السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه
هو رئيس مجلس العلاقات الخارجيه والان وهو
مركز نافذ في التاثير على السياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه وكان مسؤولا لبعض
الوقت في اداره جورج بوش الابن قال لما
سئل في 2004 لماذا ذهب الامريكان الى
العراق قال قولته المشهوره سوف اذهب الى
قبر دون ان اعرف ما فيش حاجه مقنعه لكن ما
توافر لدي من معلومات وهو رجل يعني مطلع
بشكل كبير جدا اذا كان هناك سبب واحد خفي
للهجوم الامريكي على العراق فهو الرغبه
الموجوده لدى امريكا في استعاده هيبتها
اراد الامريكان ان يثبتوا انهم قادرون على
الحاق الادب الاخرين كما الحق بهم الاذى
ارادوا ببساطه ان يثبتوا انهم ليسوا
عملاقا بلا حول له ولا قوه عملاق قوي
ومؤثر وله حول وقوه طيب اذا كنت تريد ان
تنتق م وتستعيد هيبتك كان من الطبيعي ان
توجه غضبك لمين للجهه الاولى اللي هي محل
الشك القاعده والدوله التي تاويها يعني
اسامه بن لادن وجماعتهم وطالبان التي كانت
تاويها والتي رفضت تسليمهم
وقد حدث لكن يبدو ان ده ما كانش كافي كبش
فداء لابد من البحث عن كبش فداء اخر مين
اللي كان ممكن يكون كبش فداء اخر كان
العراق كبشه فداء مثالي جدا مش بس لانه
صدام حسين كان في نظر الامريكان هو اكثر
حكام الارض شرا ولا ان هم كانوا في حاله
حرب معهم منذ حرب تحرير الكويت سنه 90
ولكن لانه وفقا للقانون الامريكي كان على
كان الامريكان ملتزمين بتغيير النظام في
العراق ايه حكايه القانون الامريكي في
اكتوبر 98 اقر بالك لينتن قانونا يجعل
السياسه الرسميه للولايات المتحده هي
الاطاحه بصدام حسين لكن بالكلينتن اقر هذا
القانون ولم يفعله لم يسعى لتغيير النظام
فعلا القانون ده اقر 97 مليون دولار تصرف
لجماعات معارضه
في محاوله لاسقاط النظام لم يصرف منها
مليم واحد ودي قصه طويله لم يكن مقتنعا
ولكنه فعل ذلك تحت ضغوط جماعات شديده
الحماس لاسقاط صدام وهذه الجامعات سوف
نتحدث عنها بعد قليل
بالكلينتن ومن سبقه من رؤساء امريكا كان
حريص على فكره ان لا ينهار العراق تماما
مش حبا في العراق ولكن حتى لا تصعد قوه
ايران في المنطقه وانه من الضروري ان يكون
هناك توازن وهو ذا التوازن او هذا الحرص
على التوازن هو الخله ريجن اثناء الحرب
العراقيه
الايرانيه طوال 8 سنوات انه يحاول انه
يدعم كل طرف حتى يقوى فيدعم الطرف الاخر
وهكذا يعني
لكن ده كان سبب ثاني انه بالفعل رسميا انه
العراق موجود على قوائم الامريكيه رسميا
اللي كنظام يجب تغييره انما ده ممكن يشرح
لنا ليه كان الولايات المتحده راغبه في
عقاب صدام حسين ليه الولايات المتحده يمكن
ان توجه ضربه لصدام حسين ليه الولايات
المتحده يمكن ان تفعل قانون تحرير العراق
الصادر سنه 98 وتحاول اسقاط النظام لكن لا
يفسر لنا الحماس الشديد جدا ليس لضرب
العراق ولكن الاحتلال والاحتلال معناه
قوات كبيره على الارض وتكلفه كبيره جدا
واحتمال خسائر هائله في صفوف الامريكان
التفسير بياخذنا الى طبيعه اداره الرئيس
جورج بوش الابن سنه 2001 اللي كان بيسيطر
عليها ما يسمى بالمحافظين الجدد
والمحافظين الجدد ديت جماعه
تشكلت
بهذا الاسم بعد انتهاء الحرب البارده
وسقوط الاتحاد السوفيتي في
91.92 وكان لها تصور متشدد جدا فيما يتعلق
بالسياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه
وكانت بطرى انه رغم يعني انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي لا يجب على الامريكان ان يضعوا
السلاح جانبا وعليهم ان يتبعوا سياسه
خارجيه
اجريسيف يعني شرسه للسيطره على كل الدول
العالم وفي قناعتهم ان هذه السيطره او
الهامانه الامريكيه سوف تكون هيمنه خيره
للعالم طيبه ليه طيبه لان الولايات
المتحده قوه استثنائيه في قوتها وفي نبلها
زي ما قال قلت برامز هو من المحافظين
الجدد وما زال نافذا في السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه امريكا هي اعظم قوه للخير على
الارض تجريتستوفورس
وانه هي ليه قوه خيره لانها بتتبنى قيم
نبيله وهذه القيم النبيله كل شعوب العالم
تتوق اليها قيم الحريه الديمقراطيه
الليبراليه السوق المفتوح ودي قصه
تناولناها سابقا في حلقه بعنوان لماذا
تعتقد امريكا انها خير امه اخرجت للناس
ممكن ان تعودوا اليها وسوف اضع لكم رابطها
على العموم هذا هذه الجماعه كانت هامشيه
في الحزب الجمهوري بعد في اول التسعينات
ظروف الحزب خسارته للانتخابات سنه سته
وتسعين خلت حد مؤثر في الحزب الجمهوري زي
نيوتن اللي كان رئيس مجلس النواب يدفع بها
للصداره ثم كان دفعها للصداره في نفس
الفتره اللي بدا يصعد فيها جورج بوش الابن
كان مرشح وجاء الى الاداره وكان كثير من
اقطاب ادارته من هذا التيار الجديد
المحافظين الجدد
اللي هم صاغوا عقيدته ما سمي بعقيده بوش
اللي حكمت سياسته الخارجيه وقال له
خلاصتها برده انه يجب توجيه او القيام
بعمليات عسكريه استباقيه للحفاظ على هيمنه
امريكا حول العالم ومحاوله تصفيه كل
الجيوب المارقه والرافده لامريكا الجيوب
الرافده والمارقه ديت على امريكا في هذه
الفتره كان عددهم محدود جدا على راسهم
العراق
انما المساله كانت اكبر من مجرد بسط
النفوذ الامريكي على العالم ومحاوله
التخلص من نظام مارق على الامريكان او
تاديبه مساله كانت اعمق بالنسبه للمحافظين
الجدد المساله كانت مرتبطه بمخطط كبير 11
سبتمبر احياه ولم يخلقوا المخطط كان موجود
والمخطط ده ليس سرا المخطط ده انه
الولايات المتحده
تدخل الى العراق تطيح بصدام
تولي او يعني تعين حكومه مواليه للامريكان
حكومه مواليه لافكارها ومواليه لحلفائها
وعلى راسهم اسرائيل وهذه الحكومه سوف
تتبنى الديمقراطيه والحريه والقيم
الامريكيه ثم منها تنتشر العدوى الحميده
والطيبه للديمقراطيه والحريه والصداقه مع
طبعا بالضروره يعني ما حلفاء امريكا اللي
هي اسرائيل الى كل الدول منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وبالتالي تتغير كل منطقه الشرق
الاوسط معقول الكلام ده الذي يبدو ساذجا
الان يكون كان فكره مطروحه ومش بس فكره
مطروحه تحول الى مخطط ايوه الكلام ده
والسر اولا هذه النيه
الرئيس جورج بوش الابن ورمز فيلد والها
عشرات المرات اكتفي لكم بمثال واحد قبل
الحرب يعني مثلا ديكتشينى قال في 26 اغسطس
2002 عندما تنتهي الاخطار الكبرى يقصد بها
ازاله صدام حسين فان الشعوب المحبه للحريه
في المنطقه سوف يكون لديها الفرصه لنشر
وتبني القيم التي تحقق السلام الدائم سوف
يعيد المتطرفون التفكير في استراتيجيتهم
القائده على القائمه على الجهاد سوف يتمكن
او يتشجع المعتدلون ويتولوا الصداره سوف
تتعزز فرص السلام بين الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين طب الكلام ده يبدو كلام
انشائي كلام الانشائي ده لا يصبح مجرد
كلاما انشائيا حين نفهم المخطط اللي اعدوا
المحافظين الجدد بدعم اسرائيلي كامل
ونشرته صحيفه وول ستريت جيرمن في وقت مبكر
جدا في 21 مارس 2003 يعني بعد اندلاع
الحرب بيوم
التحقيق القيم اللي انا واضع لحضراتكم
رابطه وعنوانه بوش دريمز
وبتشينجن بوش لا يحلم بتغيير نظام ولكن
بتغيير منطقه باكملها اول ثلاث سطور في
التحقيق بتقول ايه بينما يرسل بوش قواته
ومقاتلاته الى العراق فانه لا يفكر فقط في
تغيير نظام بلد ولكن في تغيير الشرق
الاوسط باكمله ليجعل منه مكانا مختلفا
مكانا اكثر امانا لمصالح الامريكيه وبتشرح
بالتفصيل المخطط اللي انا بكلم حضراتكم
عليه يدخل الامريكان يطيح به صدام يعينه
حكومه مواليه الحكومه المواليه سوف تنشر
قيم الديمقراطيه اللي توقعوا ان العراق
جاهز ويتوق اليها زي كل شعوب العالم
وبالتالي تنتقل هذه العدوى الى سوريا
ولبنان واليمن كل الدول ليبيا ايران الى
اخره وان المخطط ده قد يقتدي من الامريكان
ان يستخدموا القوه في بدايته لكن ما ان
ترى شعوب هذه العالم هذه المنطقه من
العالم يعني اثار الديمقراطيه فسوف
يتبنوها بشكل تلقائي دون الحاجه لاستخدام
القوه لاجبارهم عليها
الفكره دي ما اتولدتش في مع مجيء جورج بوش
المحافظين الجدد كانوا الفكره موجوده
لديهم وصاغوها في دراسه شهيره اسمها كلين
بريك
دي دراسه اعدها بعض اقطاب المحافظين الجدد
الامريكان للسياس الامريكي للسياسي
الاسرائيلي الصاعد مجموه في ذلك الوقت
والطامح لان يكون في مركز قيادي في
اسرائيل واللي كان بيعيش في الولايات
المتحده لفترات طويله بنيامين نتنياهو
والدراسه دي خلاصتها
بلاش لا يجب على الاسرائيلين ان يطبقوا
اتفاقات اسلو اللي كانت بتبشر الى سلام
قائم على حل الدولتين في اول التسعينات
عليهم ان يستخدموا القوه بدلا من ذلك
للقضاء على الانظمه المتطرفه الرافده
لاسرائيل وزوال هذه الانظمه بالقوه سوف
يجبر الفلسطينيين على قبول التصورات
الاسرائيليه للحل النهائي بتصفيه طموحاتهم
في وجود دوله فلسطينيه بطبيعه الحال
الفكره دي كانت موجوده وبمجرد ما حدثت
احداث 11 سبتمبر احييتها ولم تخلقها
ده مش بس حياتها كفكره ده جعلت جعلت
تحولتها من فكره الى مخطط
الجنرال الامريكي المعروف كلارك وزلي قال
نصا صوت وصوره وانا وضع لحضراتكم الفيديو
اللي قال فيه القصه مهمه جدا القصه دي
بتقول انه راح يقابل وزير الدفاع رمز فيلد
بعد عشره ايام من اندلاع 11 سبتمبر
وبعد ما قبله ذهب للقاء احد اصدقائي من
كبار من من كبار ضباط هيئه الاركان
المشتركه كبار قبعه كبار
ضباط الجيش الامريكي
اللي في القياده اللي قال له التالي قال
له احنا سوف لدينا اوامر بمهاجمه العراق
بعد عشره ايام من حدوث هجمات 11 سبتمبر
وبيضيف له دون ان نعلم السبب
ليس هناك علاقه مباشره حتى الان بين صدام
و 11 سبتمبر لكن يبدو ان الاداره
الامريكيه ده تفسير الضابط الامريكي كانت
بتعتقد انه
مهاجمه بعض الدول سوف يجعل امريكا تبدو
قويه وسوف يثير الخوف والذعر في قلوب اي
دوله اخرى ربما تفكر في تكرار الهجوم على
امريكا على غرار 11 سبتمبر بيقول غادر ثم
عاد بعد سته اسابيع لزياره البنتاجون
وقابل نفس الضابط مره اخرى فبيقول له انتم
ليه هاجمته افغانستان انت قلت لي الحكومه
على العراق قال له الامور تغيرت كثيرا
واصبحت اكثر اهميه من افغانستان والعراق
لدينا الان مخطط وارى مذكره هذا المخطط
بمهاجمه
وتدمير انظمه سبع دول في المنطقه خلال خمس
سنوات الدول هي بالاضافه طبعا للعراق
وبالاضافه الافغانستان سوريا لبنان ليبي
الصومال السودان وايران دول سته دول ومعهم
العراق سبعه افغانستان تم تغيير النظام
فيها بالفعل اذا لما نفهم ان ده القديم
اللي تحول الى خطه كان موجود منذ سنوات
نقدر نفهم سبب الحماس الشديد جدا اللي وصل
الى حد الهوس مين اللي بيقول ان الحماس
لصدام حسين وصل الى حد الهوس ده كتاب
ومسؤولين كبار نقل عنهم جون مارشايمر
الشهير وزميله الاستاذ الشهير ايضا ستيفن
في كتابهما القيم
ازريل لابي اللي ارشحه اللي حضراتكم
لتقراوه كتاب بالغ الاهميه في شرح اهميه
اللوب الاسرائيلي في اسرائيل وفي نفس
الوقت دور وفي دفع بوش للحرب على العراق
بيقول في الكتاب ليس من المبالغه ان اقول
ان تصميم المحافظين الجدد
على ضرب العراق والاطاحه بالصدام تحول الى
حوس اوبشن
وانه احد المسؤولين الامريكان قال له في
يناير 2003 او الف يناير 2003 وهم بينقلوا
عنه اعتقد ان بعض هؤلاء اللي هم المحافظين
الجدد قد اصبحوا بها في جرونز
ثيولوجيك لقد اصبح لديه مهاوس ديني وليس
مجرد حماس سياسي يبدو ان التخلص من صدام
وغزو العراق اصبح وكانه دين لهم تقريبا
دين جديد
واضاف
وكانهم بيعتقدوا ان المجتمع ان امريكا سوف
تنتهي اذا لم نهاجم العراق
اللي كان بيشغل يعني منصب وزير الخارجيه
وقتها قال لاحد مراسلين واشنطن بوست بعد
احد الاجتماعات وهو مندهش جدا من الاهتمام
المبالغ جدا فيه بالعراق يا الهي ما كل
هذا الهوس والتركيز على العراق
وافق على ضرب العراق لكنه لم يكن موافقا
في البدايه ولم يكن متحمسا في النهايه cia
لم تكن متحمسه لم يكن متحمس الجيش لم يكن
متحمس ولكن هذه المجموعه النافذه هي التي
كانت متحمسه ومصممه وقدمت تصور متكامل
لرئيس مرتبك بعد حادثه كبيره وكان لهم ما
ارادوا لكن ما كان لهم ابدا ان ينجحوا
فيما ارادوا الا بحماس اسرائيل مش بس
المحافظين الجدد حماس اسرائيل والعلاقه
قويه جدا بين المحافظين الجدد واسرائيل
والحماس الاسرائيلي بغض النظر عن اللوب
الاسرائيلي حماس القد اسرائيل القت بكل
قوتها وراء دفع جورج بوش الى الذهاب الى
اسرائيل ودي قصه بقى ممكن تقراوها في
الكتاب لكن يعني يعني
فيها كلام كثير جدا لكن نكتفي بانه كل
تكتفي بمثال او اثنين انه كل القيادات
الاسرائيليه الكبيره الاسرائيليه مش
اللوبي اليهودي اللي موجود في امريكا
جاؤوا الى الولايات المتحده ليدفعوا اداره
بوش دفعه اتجاه ضرب العراق يعني زي مين زي
بين يمين نتنياهو اللي زار الولايات
المتحده في 2002 وزاره مجلس الشيوخ وقابل
مراكز صنع قرار مختلفه وقلب النص كده ان
الحاجه الملحه لاسقاط صدام لها اهميه قصوى
وان الحمله حمله الحرب على العراق تستحق
الدعم غير المشروط من جميع الحكومات
العاقله
ما يؤلف 2002
مثل بن لادن يجب ان تتخلصوا منه
اهوت براك في مقال كبير في صحيفه الوشم
بوست بوش اولا وقبل كل شيء يجب عليه
التركيز على العراق وازاحه صدام حسين اولا
بمجرد رحيل سوف يكون هناك عالم عربي مختلف
شارون بيقول للناس في مجلس الشيوخ في جلسه
مغلقه اذا نجحتم في التخلص من صدام فسوف
تكون قد انهيت بالكثير من مشكلات اسرائيل
الامنيه وكان لهم ما ارادوا مجموعه من
الملاحظات الملحوظه الاولى انه
هذا المخطط ما كان له ان ينتقل من فكره
الى مخطط وخطه عمل لولا انه العراق والجيش
العراقي كان فيه اضعف احواله يعني لو
الامريكان وتقديرتهم ان العراق كان دوله
قويه ما كان لهم ان يخاطروا بخسائر كبيره
فيها لكن المخطط كان مغري جدا واحد
اسباب كونه مغريا مش بس انه هتترتب عليه
وفقا لتصوراتهم فوائد جمه ولكن التكلفه
محدوده وفقا للتصوراتهم يعني رمز فيلد
تتوقع ان الحرب تنتهي خلال خمسه ايام خمسه
اسابيع خمسه اشهر على الاكثر لكن ليس اكثر
من ذلك جورج بوش الابن واهما في واحد مايو
يعني بعد حوالي سته اسابيع من الحرب قال
مش انا خلصت المهمه كانت تصور انه لن تكون
هناك اي خسائر تذكر هذا اولا
الامر الثاني انه
التصور بانه حرب العراق يمكن ان تغير
الشرق الاوسط يبدو الان ساذجا جدا لكنه
وقتها ما كانش على هذا النحو من السذاجه
كانت القناعه دي موجوده
وانه فعلا يمكن تغيير المنطقه لان مش
العراق بس ضعيف ده العراق ضعيف ودول
المنطقه كلها لا حول لها ولا قوه
وبالمناسبه هذا التصور الساذج بيبقى مدهش
بالنظر الى ان العقول الاسرائيليه
والامريكيه اللي سوقت ليه بعضها عقول
كبيره جدا وده بيضع علامات استفهام عليه
ومالهم فعلا عقول كبيره ولا اصحاب عقول
ساذجه ولا اصحاب عقول كبيره لكن لما الامر
بيتعلق باسرائيل
بتحكمهم او بيحكمهم الوجه الامنيات مش
التفكير المنطقي لانه لما تيجي تتامل كده
التاريخ الحديث هتلاقي انه في افكار كبيره
ومشروعات طموحه جدا زي هذا التصور القائم
اللي سوقوا له بعد 2003 كتير يعني شارون
مثلا لما دخل اسرائيل في سنه 82 كان تصوره
مش ان انا ادخل لبنان واعاقبهم او احتل
الجنوب ده كان فكرته ان انا اقيم دويله
مسيحيه في جنوب لبنان وان الدويله ديت سوف
يعني تكون حليف لاسرائيل وبالتالي يعني
تساعده في الهيمنه على كامل لبنان وتقضي
على الوجود الفلسطيني وهناك كان تصور ساذج
جدا لكنه ذهب الى تنفيذه
الربيع العربي والحماس الامريكي الكبير في
بدايته من جانب اوباما قائم برضو على تصور
سيادك اننا ممكن اعيد هندسه كامل منطقه
الشرق الاوسط من خلال تصور بدا على الورق
عظيم جدا الولايات المتحده تدعم جماعات
اسلاميه على راسها الاخوان المسلمين ودي
جماعات محبوبه جدا في الشارع العربي وسوف
يكون لها قبول وجماهيريه وفي نفس الوقت هم
مستعدين للتحالف مع الامريكان وبالتالي
يحققوا
يعني الهدوء وعلاقه جديده قويه في دول
الشرق الاوسط بتكلفه لا تذكر اذا الثلاجه
ما هياش عجيبه ولا غريبه الملحوظه
الثالثه انه الان هذا السيناريو اللي هو
الدفع الاداره الامريكيه بمغامره على امل
تغيير منطقه الشرق الاوسط كلها بشكل يخدم
المصالح الامريكيه وياخدو اكتر طبعا
المصالح الاسرائيليه يتكرر الان مره اخرى
هناك لوبي وحمله قويه جدا
للدفع باللغات المتحده بمواجهه جديده لكن
هذه المره ليس مع العراق ولكن مع ايران
الذي يؤجل تكرار هذا السيناريو هو التجربه
المؤلمه للامريكان في العراق من ناحيه
وانه ايران دوله الان اقوى بكثير مما كانت
العراق عليه في 2003 والا لقاموا بضرب
ايران منذ سنوات طويله
ملحوظه اخيره
الثابت انه
شارون الذي كان رئيس وزراء في سنه 2003
عارض في البدايه فكره ان يسعى الامريكان
لضرب العراق ليس رغبه في الحفاظ على صدام
ولكن خوف من انه ضرب العراق اللي كان
متداعي وضعيف ربما يمنع الامريكان من ضرب
سوريا وضرب ايران اللي كانوا في وضع اقوى
بعد انهيار العراق
اثراء يعني هزيمته وطرده من الكويت في سنه
90 ولم يتحمس هو وكل اللوبي الاسرائيلي
والمسؤولين الاسرائيليين
لضرب العراق الا حين اطمئن ان ضرب العراق
لن يكون الا بدايه تتلوه قائمه طويله على
راسها طبعا ايران وسوريا قصه طويله مؤلمه
ذات شبون تستحق ان نتابعها
في مرات اخرى باذن الله اشكركم والى لقاء